and uh let's just jump to the first
story that will kick off the the general
conversation
from the daily mail donald trump leaves
walter reed after three nights battling
covet
and takes off his mask as soon as he
lands the white house
where he will take more experimental
drugs and i love how they phrase this is
like fun
and promises to be back on the campaign
trail soon so we have some bullet points
trump arrived back at the white house
monday night taking off his face mask to
enter the building i'm sure the
journalists are screaming oh no now he's
getting people sick
the president left walter reed after
spending three nights he walked out at 6
40 which is about what he expected at 6
45 the
helicopter took off and it landed at 6
55 marine one crew will have to isolate
for 14 days and the helicopter will have
to be deep cleaned
the 74 year old president tweeted on
monday afternoon
that he was feeling better than i did 20
years ago his treatment yeah
well he's hopped up on goofballs okay
his treatment will continue at the white
house with doctors on monday saying he
was not out of the woods
trump told his supporters don't be
afraid of covet don't let it dominate
your life
the virus has claimed more than two
hundred and ten thousand american lives
and more than one million worldwide on
monday white house press secretary kelly
mcinerney became the 14th person
in his circle to test positive anonymous
aides said on monday
that trump had grown tired of watching
news coverage of his health
yeah and as it turns out the unhinged
conspiracies across the board were
totally wrong
i don't know if you guys were were
tracking what these journalists were
saying
you've been seeing it i mean i've i saw
one journalist say that she had some
anonymous source report that trump was
like on his death bed
he might pass away imminently and and i
was also simultaneously seeing that he's
actually just
faking it to get these debates it's like
whatever the trump is doing the bad
thing the bad thing could be many
one of many possibilities we're not sure
which one but just know that something's
not on the up and up because trump you
know what's really annoying to me is
like
i don't know how many times i can tell
people that
everything trump does is wrong so so
look people i i got some messages from
friends they're like man it's it's i
hate the media morning huh like every
segment you've done has been
the media is bad these people i'm like
yeah because like
all throughout this this this new cycle
with trump and kovid it's been
a rollercoaster of emotions is he faking
it
is whatever he's doing it's wrong okay
so he's faking it what a jerk then they
took pictures of him working and they're
like the pictures are fake
it's like okay like even the pictures he
took are
bad yeah everything is bad i saw yahoo
news speculating that
they were trying to make it look like
trump was working over several days
because he was
wearing different clothes in different
locations it's like the man takes off
his
suit jacket and then goes to a different
room and it's this big conspiracy where
he's apparently trying to make it look
like what what are you talking about
so so that that was one of my favorite
conspiracies because i actually had
these resistance people tweet at me and
then delete their tweets
this is funny so this one was there's a
photo
of trump he's wearing his suit jacket no
tie though and he's like signing a paper
the first conspiracy theory the paper
was blank no
it's just called blown out when when
when the the light is trying to adjust
for like a lower light area and you have
a white reflection yeah it blows out the
image you can't see anything on it
so i thought it was blank they're
literally photos of obama doing the same
thing so that was the first conspiracy
which they still
are pushing how insane the next was
the exif data that's right when you take
a picture
all right and then publish it there's a
bunch of information stored on that
image like
what kind of camera it was was there a
flash where and when the photo was taken
the only issue with this conspiracy i
love it so much is that there's also a
caption that says donald trump as seen
at the white house after being diagnosed
at walter reed after being diagnosed
with kovid and so they're all saying
like these two photos are taken 10
minutes apart
and i'm like but there's a caption in it
meaning someone ran it through a
rendering program
and created a new file yeah and so i
tried explaining to people
that the reason the date is 10 minutes
off is
probably because the photographer loaded
a bunch of raw files into
a program and then added the captions
and then compressed them down
creating new files and so after saying
that's a very simple explanation
actually someone say no you were wrong
all that would do is change the
modification date
so it would say date modified not date
created
or at the exit date next xf data is uh
not date created because it's
specifically about the camera on when
the camera and i'm just like dude
do do these people really think that the
associated press photographer
is in on it yeah like had a meeting with
trump and they were like yeah
so so trump was like we're going to
stage this to make it look like i'm
working and the photographer was like
i'm the journalist who's another
conspiracy so are journalists good guys
or enemies of people
okay are they working with trump a
fascist dictator to make him look good
or did they just render a new file that
has
improper data right like it's it that's
it's just conspiracy world
and they're allowed to do it well what i
find so
hypocritical about all this is like we
remember during the 2016 election there
was all this speculation over hillary's
health
and we were told that that is just it's
because of actually sexism
and just conspiracy theories and never
mind that but i mean biden
a lot of people do believe he has
cognitive decline right but
like the media never talks about it
doesn't report on it but all of a sudden
trump essentially you know gets the flu
and
like non-stop for the past like what 70
some hours i remember i was looking for
a story to talk about and i did not want
to talk
about trump having covid because i mean
doesn't
what am i supposed to do with that uh
but yeah there was nothing else because
this completely consumed everybody
they're gonna get us for this one
because the covet is not the flu
but they're gonna they're gonna clip it
they're gonna clip it and they're gonna
be like lauren chen
is pushing cons i'm not even these
people are not yeah so
trump got covered the survival rate for
i think people in his
in his bracket is like 70 i'm sorry it's
uh he's 74 so it's like
95 yeah and it's actually like pretty
scary but it's because he's obese
and he's older and he's older but i
don't think his diet is that great
yeah he looks like mcdonald's all the
time what did he what's he saying
something like wasn't he eating
mcdonald's recently is or was that a
joke someone was joking about like
mcdonald's is going to make him strong
and like get him through this
he loves he loves fast food so i know
somebody who used to cover his
his uh like his campaigns for a while
and they would fly on the plane with him
and everything
and they said he's always eating fast
food they also said he was a really nice
guy like he would like offer people like
you know
you know if you want anything yeah man
but that he's he's a germaphobe
so that this for this is the craziest
thing they used to say
i remember covering trump's campaign
back in 2015 and 16. they're like the
dude's totally germaphobic
he like always always wiping his hands
off and he doesn't like touching things
and the only reason he eats fast food
and he doesn't like going other places
is because they have uniform standards
interesting so he's like the food is all
made manufactured in a factory
so he's he's not worried about like
tainted meat and stuff like that for the
most part
so it's like i know i'm getting the same
standard at every place but if you go to
a
like a small restaurant you can get food
poisoning or something yeah to hear like
so i i know journalists who are like
yeah trump is
like uh a germaphobe and then to hear
them complain about him not wearing a
mask i'm like that's kind of weird to me
because the dude is like
germaphobic older guy he's like always
wiping his hands down and stuff
and i think the issue with the mask is
just like
it's to stop other people from getting
sick so i wonder if like trump was just
like i don't care or whatever you know
but then but then trump gets sick and
then also the conspiracy is erupt yeah i
mean like to the uh the stan
the comment about fast food places
having standards i mean i'm sure there
are a lot of people watching can testify
to
the fact that you know places like taco
bell being a chain and having supposedly
universal standards not necessarily
protection
against fast food hey hey taco bell's
all right
i like it i think it's worth it you know
you roll the dice what happens happens
it's still good food meant to be yeah
yeah
you know you could get a bowl
obstruction or you could clear yourself
out one or the other depending on what
you get we never know
did anyone ever figure out what trump's
uh secret cocktail of medicine was
i love how the i love how they're like
experimental drugs yeah what is he
taking
like so uh you know look trump's fine
i don't i it's ridiculous because even
though covet
it's worse than the flu it's a serious
thing the the main issue that needs to
be clarified with covet is that
it as a novel virus we didn't know how
to treat it we're actually at the point
now
where we do know and one of the
interesting things about all this is
that they were like why are they giving
trump this medicine or that medicine
and then there were actual people saying
like it's because we changed how we're
treating it
it's been it's been seven months or
whatever you know we've we've
changed our course of treatment like
they're not they're not doing intubation
anymore
those were damaging people right right
and so now they're just like
supplemental oxygen not ventilated
and you give them these these
medications and trump is fine there's a
couple days
are they still doing the the plasma
treatments for people who have it more
seriously
i don't know but that's complex yeah
that is plasma yeah it's really cool
yeah i was reading about that
we talked about that with somebody
remember who it was so where it's like
they take your blood out
and then they run it along like this
membrane like put oxygen in it yeah
that's crazy yeah weinstein was saying
that it
might have been damaging the hemoglobin
um in the cells this is the virus itself
yeah yes and that's why so they were
they weren't able the cells weren't able
to transfer oxygen it wasn't that you
needed more air in your lungs
because the cells themselves were having
a hard time yeah
mitochondria is the powerhouse of the
sun pretty much my
you nailed it that's exactly it that
explains everything no but
i love this uh uh i mean the point i'm
trying to get to earlier is like
i'm not trying to drag or or mock the
man because he's sick you know i
wish him the best but the reason why i
think it's totally okay to make jokes
about this is because we knew he was
going to be fine
you know and there was like comments
about how like oh you got to be solomon
don't
don't mock the president well there's
one it's one thing if you're like
trump is a [ __ ] what a dumb okay that's
that's not
poking fun but like you know if i were
to you know post a meme of trump
there was a funny meme of uh trump with
it was willy wonka with trump's face
you guys know this we're like wonka
walks out with a cane and then he falls
over but it's trump
and then someone there's another meme
where it's a whole bunch of conservative
faces
i don't even know what the movie is but
it's like trump is babe ruth and then
he like hits a home field of dreams no
no no i don't know what it is
he's not babe ruth but he's like he's
playing baseball and then the ball is
the coronavirus
and they throw it and then trump hits it
and it's like you know how they do the
deep fake thing
yeah that's going viral yeah it was like
trump's face and then you had a bunch of
conservatives on the
shooting the the re-dub up you did the
the wwe thing with him like
they've done the cnn version but now
there's the coronavirus version where
it's just like
the guy's head is actually just the
coronavirus this is so good for him
i think so yeah yeah because it was only
three days
so the the the worrying thing is that
you know kaylee mcinerney today
reported that she was asymptomatic but
she tested positive and
trump definitely needs her because she
is like the fake news buster
i love her i'm a huge fan she's she got
the binder yeah it's amazing yeah
i'm just imagining her like you know
putting on the ghostbuster jumpsuit all
the journalists
yeah yeah but she's so she's you know
gonna be
in some somewhat inhibited now because
she's got a quarantine and then if trump
did have to isolate or still does
that's bad i mean this is this is this
is the home stretch man this is where
trump
needs to kick it up a notch yeah they
need to be on the campaign trail well
actually and speaking of all these like
coronavirus testing
results i don't know if you folks have
seen from the new york times oh gosh was
the new york times new york post but
there was this report about how the
like the the sensitivity of a lot of
coveted tests are actually
too great yeah um so they might be more
more confirmed cases than there should
be some of the people who are testing
positive might have either
uh had it months ago and they're no
longer contagious or might have been
contaminated in the lab and actually um
westphalian times they just did a report
looking in canada
and it's the same thing there as well
and i'm sure you know probably in most
developed countries where they're doing
this
we might actually be kind of
quarantining people who don't
have it and who aren't necessarily
susceptible to passing it on
and destroying the economy and lives in
the process there were a bunch of
there were a bunch of stories recently
where they like reduced the number and
they're like oops
you know you know 200 of those were
wrong and then like just got rid of them
there was one i i i want to be really
careful with numbers because we don't
have the
sources pulled up and i you know
definitely got to be careful there but
there was there there were some stories
i saw where like a substantive number of
the confirmed cases were just wiped out
like that was a mistake
yeah and then there was another viral
story this is crazy i think it was in
texas
where they said that likely cases are
added to the total number of cases
so in order to be a likely case you had
to be in
proximity with someone and then have two
symptoms
so like if you visited your mom
and then a week later your mom said she
was like sneezing at it and had a cough
they'd be like that's a covet case and
then add it to the total without testing
yeah oh my god but the crazy thing about
that is like what if they just have
allergies
yeah what if it's a cold what you know
it's like i mean i have i've had a runny
nose for the past four years at this
point
oh my gosh so you're you're patient zero
i'm pretty yeah
pretty much i'm giving you all
chronicles oh okay thank you
gluten intolerance is pretty prevalent
in society that causes people to like
sneeze and have runny nose and yeah get
a fever
i mean there's hay fever yes like you
you hang out with your mom
then you go home and then all sudden
like a flower farts in your face like
that's how it works i mean i don't i
don't know about you guys but any time
now where i'm in public and i have to
sneeze or cough i like
sometimes you're very conscious about it
because
oh yeah i go straight forward are you
guys i i add uh
several decibels what if i'm going to
sneeze normally my skin is like i do i
go
no i'm kidding he totally does i'm so
ready for this to finish
i don't know about you guys but when i
when i see people with masks i just get
angry i get frustrated sad i get more
sad than anything and i'm just
like why that why because it's just i
don't want to speak
about my feelings on it publicly without
proof or anything but i just feel like
it's so ridiculous and overblown
like we've gone way too far we've shut
down way too much for something with a
99 percent recovery rate is that 99.995
oh come on
yeah yeah no no i'm sorry it's like 99.5
oh
no is it i think it's super high no i
think it is 99.9
yeah it's really really and i mean the
thing is a lot of people are saying well
is it better if people just
like would you rather have people just
die and i don't think they understand
that
people are missing things like cancer
screenings right there are surgeries
that are being delayed there are people
now who won't be able to
do things like pay for their medical
bills like that it's a lot of a bigger
deal than just saying oh we'll wait to
get your hair cut and sometimes
and depression which oh for sure i don't
know how quantifiable it is but so i i
lost a friend
an old good friend i'm sure it has
something to do with covet quarantine
you know whatever it was people were
losing their minds i mean during the uh
the last recession like there were
actually marked increases in things like
suicides unfortunately and
uh you know alcohol has been on all of
that stuff so this is actually it's
taking a real human toll
so i i agree and actually it's kind of
depressing because where i live
you know in quebec montreal we're
actually entering a new phase of
lockdowns
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time